I was gonna get two it's the same basic
principle which is I really respect my
haters yeah I truly know [ __ ]
respect them because it's how they feel
now it takes me time sometimes to dig in
and to are they unhappy people is there
other things going on you know did I do
something wrong by accident because I
never have that intent but if somebody
thinks you stink that means you're doing
a bad job communicating to them of what
your value proposition is I I respect my
haters the people that don't agree with
me are easy when I say haters I mean
people that are being rude or unkind to
me I respect it I take it very seriously
I try to understand it and I've evolved
from it I reach out to it you know
ninety percent are thrilled to be heard
for you know to have that dialogue
there's a lot of times they're surprised
that I'm even willing to go there
because nobody has the time the ten
percent that wanted to draw a line in
the sand and dislike me it bothers me
but you know I try my best and hope it
you know I know
I know how my parents raised me I know
what my Jacobs are I wrote a piece on
medium which is an incredible blog
platform that I think everybody should
you should be seriously paying attention
to medium okay check where I wrote
there's two ways to build the biggest
building in town right there's two ways
one you just build it you build the
largest building or number two you tear
down all the other buildings around you
we live in a very cynical world where a
lot of people do number two I take
enormous pride in number one I love when
listen I was one of the first video
bloggers ever I love sitting here
knowing video bloggers have you know
gone further than where I went if that
doesn't make me sad it makes me happy
right now you know III want other people
to win as long as I win more I'm
competitive yeah but that's on me right
that's not me being on a defense of
everybody else that's not me saying of
that's not good right this guy's not
good this girl's not good that's me
being on the offense right and so let's
have a look at it